this is the Joo underground podcast
number 92 sitting here with Echo Charles
here's a common question for us and by
us I mean humans should I focus on
capitalizing on my strengths or should I
focus on improving my
weaknesses like I said common question
actually Echo Charles you most recently
asked me this common question
sure my answer is actually yes that's my
answer to both yeah but I would
say have a bias of focusing time on
strength so if you've got strength and
weaknesses which you do you should work
on both you should bias towards working
on your strengths in most
cases
because well for one thing it you have a
compounding effect when you're good at
something it allows other opportunities
right other things open up allows you to
do more even that thing that you're good
at
you can do it faster because you're good
at it you can do it with more efficiency
and that means you can see other things
that are happening so that's good and
it's usually some kind of an exponential
growth when you're doing something that
you're good
at so we want to focus on our strength
for sure but that doesn't mean abandon
your weaknesses you shouldn't give up on
them you should still work on them but
let's say you're great at
writing no let's say let's say you
aren't greater let's say you're not good
at writing that's I think that's a
little more common someone that's just
not really good at writing don't really
like it but you're really good at
math that doesn't mean oh I should go
and try and become a
journalist right so if you aren't great
at writing don't go to college to become
a journalist right that's not a good
move yeah if you're good at math not
good at writing go be an engineer go be
a computer scientist do do something
that is going to capitalize on what
you're good at but don't just give up on
writing don't just abandon
it take some of those classes take a
creative writing class take an English
literature class you know write in your
Journal so you can get better at it yeah
because it is a skill that you're going
to need even if you're even if you're
just a in a complete math oriented world
you're still going to have to write
you're still going to have to write even
if you're writing if you're a a
scientist you're going to have to write
an application to get a gram
or whatever yeah I'm totally talking
about things I don't know about but I
know that those people get grants I know
you got to write an application to get a
grant so therefore you're running so you
should try and get good at it same thing
if you're naturally like a
lean endurance athlete if that's what
you kind of naturally are you shouldn't
be like Oh I'm going to now become a I'm
my goal is to become a
powerlifter because chances are you're
going to top out and you're going
against nature yeah right you're
naturally lean naturally have slow
twitch
fibers so that doesn't mean so so don't
go try and become a Power
lifter
but that doesn't mean you should uh
never lift right you should want to be
strong now listen if you're a if you're
an Olympic marathon runner you're
probably not going to be lifting a bunch
at least not upper body right I don't
think they left I don't they don't look
like they left seem yeah doesn't seem
like they're lifting but my point is for
a normal person you're oh you're
naturally a good runner cool definitely
keep running but that doesn't mean
abandon lifting still want to be
stronger that kind of
thing and there are also
things that if you're not good at
them they're so important that you
actually have to do them anyways M so
for instance the Jiu-Jitsu sure let's
say you wrestled yeah and when you grow
up you wrestling so you hate being on
the bottom you don't want to be in your
back so you have no guard
yeah that's not going to there's going
to be here's the here's the problem with
that there's someone out there that's a
better wrestler than you period end of
story right there's someone out there
that's going to put you on your
back and it might be you know if you
wrestled in college well if you wrestled
in a junior college well then the D1
colleges they're going to be all better
wrestlers than you so they're going to
put you on your back so you got to just
you know I had a fighter one time and I
said hey you know let's work of your
bottom game he's like I'm not going to
the
bottom and I said yeah but you should
still have it mhm and he didn't didn't
work on it and he got beat grounded
pounded for three rounds taken down each
round and he was a guy that was really
hard to hold down
MH I would have a hard time holding him
down you know he had a good you good
feet on the hips and getting back to his
feet and it was hard to take down
too but got taken down three
rounds and didn't have his timing didn't
have his you know you learn some tricks
down there of how you're going to get
back up
yeah so there are critical things that's
why I should I used writing as an
example writing is actually kind of a
really important skill to have in
general in life yeah if you can't write
well you can't even really put together
a good application to apply for a job
never mind a grant you can't explain
things correctly in the in the military
you're not good at writing evaluations
you're not good at writing Awards like
there's all kinds of problems so writing
is not a great example because writing
actually is something that you should
get good
at I had
uh I didn't really like being on the
bottom very much in Jiu-Jitsu when I
started yeah probably because I was like
bigger and stronger so when I was on top
I could like use my weight and strength
to control people and so what I did I
realized I didn't like it and so I just
ended up starting on the bottom for like
a year straight yeah and I got so
confident on the bottom that I brought
my game back up to speed
so that's a positive thing because if
you're not good on the bottom what
happens when you get put on the bottom
you're going to get smashed in trouble
so you have to do that now what's
interesting about this
is you know you think about what your
weaknesses are
mhm I think a lot of
times you mistake your weaknesses for
something that you lack the natural
ability to do when the reality is you
just haven't really worked on it yeah
you know what I'm saying like you you oh
you're this guy's not a good striker in
in fighting well how much does he train
striking of course he's a black belt in
jiujitsu and he trains seven days a week
on the mats but he doesn't really so
he's not a good Striker he hasn't
trained every single day for 10 years in
Striking yeah because he doesn't really
like it that much and why doesn't he
like it that much cuz he doesn't do it
very much so when he does go Spar he
kind of gets his ass kicked and so if
there's something that you're not good
at chances are it's not that you don't
have the natural ability just that you
haven't worked on it and that's a
problem so sometimes people think I
don't want to do that they hide from it
and that's a bad thing to do especially
from a leadership perspective yeah you
know if I come down and I see the troops
are doing something that's something I
don't feel really comfortable with so I
just kind of like hide from it not a
good move instead be like hey can you
guys walk me through this because I
don't really know how to do it yeah and
then you realize oh it's just oh it's
just that I don't know how to do it yet
once they teach you oh you're gonna have
to practice it a little bit then you'll
be better at it okay cool
but taking that step to go and get into
something is important
y this is a Mikey and the dragon
scenarios by the way right like when
you're looking at you know when I say
hey Eko I want you to brief the sales
team today and you're like I don't I I
don't I'm not good at public speaking
right and I go well how much have you
practiced and you're like well I've
never practiced well then you're not
going to be good at it so I think a lot
of times we see our weaknesses as
something we naturally aren't good at
but in reality we don't see that we
haven't worked at it and that other
people have worked at
it you know oh how'd that person oh I'm
not good at squats well how much are you
squatting yeah you know oh I don't have
a good you know I don't have a good
bench how much bench press are you doing
yeah so that's the reality is I'm not a
good runner how much are you
running like what are you doing now
listen there's people that you're not
going to be a an exceptional Runner
you're not going to have an
exceptionally strong bench you're not
going to have an exceptionally strong
squat but just about everybody can be
pretty good yeah you know what I'm
saying how I shouldn't say just about
anybody with the right amount of work
yeah you know what's interesting I'm not
good at
anything okay I'm not good at anything
but I do an interesting thing that I do
have is I have like good
uh mobility in my squat position sure
like there's a lot of people that can't
go to as to Grass squat you know just
I'm I'm talking like no weight I'm just
talking sitting here oh just squat down
all the way comfortably and and be able
to sit there like that
yeah I have I know people that are more
flexible kind of universally than I am
mhm but they can't do that why cuz they
they never get in that
position so if you get in that position
and you sit there you'll open up your
hips you'll improve your flexibility in
your ankles blah blah blah
yeah so I say yes work on both that's my
answer yeah there's two to your question
so the the this kind of you you're
helping me make sense of it all because
I kind of see it as so certain things
that you're naturally good at there's
kind of two little categories in a way
where it's like one that you're kind of
just natur like let's say you're twitch
muscles you're going to be better at
certain physical activities than others
right that's like you're naturally good
at it then there's another kind of
natural ability that seems natural and
technically it is but it's because
you've been put in certain environments
that sort of give you this proxy
training for this certain thing so like
you know let's say you're a farmer or
someone who bails hay or lifts up does a
lot of physical stuff just through work
and then you go do something else that's
physical in a different way but similar
you know some some overlap there or
whatever and you're going to be ahead of
like the normal person so it's like oh
this came natural to him well cuz he
spent freaking 15 years doing this other
thing that's similar you know the really
good obvious example that is water water
yeah being comfortable in the water so
anyone that grew up in the water yeah
whether they were lived by a lake lived
by the ocean they surfed they were on
the swim team they played water polo
those people are comfortable in the
water anybody that grew up where there's
no water they didn't swim
they they're a disaster in the water and
it takes a lot of work for them to
overcome that you see this all the time
in in basic SEAL training people that
grew up in the water they don't have any
problem with the water Evolutions like
like literally no problem yeah it's it's
a rest for them yeah there's some people
that are panicking on every single time
they go do a pool Evolution and the pool
Evolutions are challenging it's it's
underwater not tying it's life saving
it's 50 meter underwater swim and anyone
that grew up in the water they they they
consider those things to be a rest they
consider those things to be a rest easy
and just like any just about anyone that
ran cross country yeah in high school or
certainly in college they don't worry
about those runs at all they're like oh
oh we got a fourmile Time run today they
run a fourmile Time run in 26 minutes 25
minutes the passing time is 32 minutes
there's a bunch of people that fail
those things yeah why because they're
used to that environment
yeah so yes you're right it may seem
like oh this guy's naturally comfortable
in the water yeah the dude played
freaking water polo you know of course
he's going to seem natural in the water
and this other dude's from Iowa grew up
on a farm had never ever his face in the
water yeah yeah or you get like people
who grow up in a big family you know and
then for some reason they're real like
um you know they have certain
personality traits that are that are
conducive to other environments so like
you know you hear about people for
example they're in a big family and they
got to kind of fight for to be heard you
know so they're real tenacious in that
way and that sort of sets them up for
certain other situations you know so in
a way they got training yeah yeah but
it's just by their natural life you know
kind of a thing so there's that going on
and then there's the stuff that kind of
like how you said where you don't have
any training you actually you don't have
experience doing it that's really what
it is you don't have an experience doing
it whether it be training or just in
everyday life and then those wind up
usually or a lot of times being quote
unquote weaknesses yeah and then okay so
then moving forward again this is just
me trying to make sense of the whole
thing
where these are going to be kind of more
tech
technical Expressions so there's
training and then there's performance so
you know training is like hey you can
practice your weaknesses you can
practice your strength you practice
everything but if you can identify your
weaknesses that's the time where you can
really focus on them and it's like cool
I can improve them Slowly by slowly but
come performance time unless they're at
a certain level bro you want to avoid
that stuff you want to play to your
strength now hopefully you brought your
weaknesses up a little bit so you can at
least live or survive or you know
whatever the case may be but performance
is not the time to start working on your
weaknesses no you're right in training
so hopefully you can kind of
differentiate what are you doing right
now are you training are you performing
you know kind of a thing 100% right you
kind of make sense of it no that's a
great point you don't you know you you
don't have
good
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Joo underground podcast so
if you want to continue to listen go to
Joo underground.com And subscribe and
we're doing this to mitigate our
Reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better Communications with us strengthen
this Legion of Troopers that are in the
game with us so thank you it's Joo
underground.com it cost
$818 a month and if you can't afford to
support us we can still support you just
email assistance atjo underground.com
and we'll get you taken care of until
then we will see you
mobilized
Underground